AND, YES, OUR PATRIOTIC SPIRIT.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE FORMER
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY AND
THE ELECTION OF ININTEGRITY.
ALSO WITH ME IS BEN EDITOR AT
LARGE FOR THE SPECTATOR AND FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
BEN, IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU GUYS
TONIGHT.
WE JUST LEARNED THAT BIDEN IS
NOW IN HIS -- AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION IS BEGGING OPEC
NOT TO CONTINUE WITH ITS PLAN TO
DRAMATICALLY CUT OIL PRODUCTION.
SO NOW BIDEN -- IT HAS THAT TWO
STEP GOING ON.
HE'S CRUSHING OUR ENERGY
PRODUCTION HERE AND THEN
PROSTRATING AMERICA BEFORE
DESPITES.
HOW IS THIS GOOD FOR US?
>> IT'S SUPER -- IT'S SUPER
EASY, LAURA.
I MEAN, EVERY TIME THAT THE
PRICES GO DOWN, THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU CAN THANK PRESIDENT
BIDEN FOR.
EVERY TIME THEY GO UP, IT'S
SOMEONE ELSE'S FAULT.
LOOK, EVERYTHING THAT YOU LAID
OUT THERE IN THE ANGLE IS
COMPLETELY CORRECT.
THIS IS AN EFFORT IN GAS
LIGHTNING THAT WE'VE SEEN OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS, UNLIKE
ANYTHING THAT I'VE EVER SEEN
POLITICALLY WHERE EVERY SINGLE
TIME THAT THEY ARE CONFRONTED
WITH BEING CALLED ON THE TYPE OF
RAMIFICATIONS FOR THE POLICIES
THAT THEY'RE ADVOCATING FOR,
THEY POINT TO THE OTHER SIDE AND
SAY, OH, NO, THIS IS THEIR
FAULT.
THEY'RE THE ONES DOING THIS
THING.
THEY'RE THE ONES TEARING DOWN
OUR INSTITUTIONS.
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO ARE
ENGAGING IN DANGEROUS
ANTIDEMOCRATIC ACTIVITY.
YOU KNOW, WHEN PRESIDENT BIDEN
GOES OUT THERE AND SCARES UP ALL
SORTS OF PEOPLE ABOUT THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF THE ELECTIONS
IN ITALY JUST THE OTHER DAY, YOU
KNOW, HE'S ENGAGING IN SOMETHING
THAT IS CLEARLY ANTIDEMOCRATIC,
ANTI-ELECTIONS.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING YET THAT HE
TURNS AROUND AND SAYS, OH, WELL
I'M JUST TRYING TO DEFEND, YOU
KNOW, DEMOCRACY AGAINST THESE
DANGEROUS POPULOUS, AUTHOR
TARRIANS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
AND THIS IS THE ENTIRE APPROACH
THAT WE'VE SEEN UNDER THE OBAMA,
BIDEN ERA OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
>> IT'S A SMEAR MACHINE.
HOGAN, THE LINCOLN PROJECT
STOOGES ARE OUT IN FULL FORCE
AGAIN.
AND AGAIN, THEY HAVE REALLY NO
SUCCESSES SO IT'S ONLY TALKING
POINTS AGAINST REPUBLICANS WHO,
BY THE WAY, ARE NOT IN THE
MAJORITY.
WATCH.
>> NOW THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS
BECOME A PARTY OF MISOGYNY, A
PARTY OF RACISM, BIG TREE, OF
HYPOCRISY, OF REWARDING LIARS.
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE COMPLETELY
UNQUALIFIED TO REPRESENT ANYONE.
THEY'RE NOT QUALIFIED TO BE DOG
CATCHER.
THAT IS INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS FOR
OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> HOGAN, IT'S SO EASY TO DEFEAT
HER NONPOINTS.
IT'S ALMOST NOT WORTH BOTHERING.
BUT WHO KEPT DISADVANTAGES KIDS
LOCKED DOWN IN URBAN AREAS?
WHO PREVENTED VOUCHERS FROM
BEING GIVEN TO PARENTS TO SWITCH
SCHOOLS IF THEY WANTED TO?
WHO DID ALL OF THIS?
THE REPUBLICANS?
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
YOUR MONOLOGUE, TO ECHO BEN, IS
RIGHT ON THE POINT.
THE IRRATIONALE, ILLOGICAL, YOU
KNOW, THOUGHT PROCESS OF THE
LEFT IS SO PROBLEMATIC.
BUT THE POLICIES THEY PUT IN
PLACE IN THE LAST TWO YEARS HAVE
HURT REAL AMERICANS.
NOT THE LEFT AND THE MEDIA AND
JOE BIDEN WILL WORK TOGETHER
WILL TELL YOU ALL OF THESE
THINGS ARE HAPPENING TO HIM, ALL
OF THE PROBLEMS WE FACE ARE
HAPPENING TO JOE BIDEN.
NO, NO.
THEY'RE HAPPENING BECAUSE OF JOE
BIDEN.
AND SO ALL THE ISSUES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY GOING TO DRIVE PEOPLE
OUT TO THE POLLS.
CRIME, FOR EXAMPLE, AS YOU
POINTED OUT SPIKING ALL OVER THE
CRIME.
THE RAPES, THE BURGLARIES, THE
MURDERS.
WE CAN SEE A REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
IN OREGON OF ALL PLACES BECAUSE
OF THE DEFUND THE POLICE.
THE SOUTHERN BORDER IS WIDE
OPEN.
DRUGS POURING INTO OUR ECONOMY.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, SMILED
SMUGGLING, ALL TIMES HIGH.
AND YOU POINTED OUT THE ENERGY
CRISIS.
WE'RE PAYING MORE FOR GAS AND
GROCERIES THAN WE EVER HAVE.
AND SURPRISE, SURPRISE JOE BIDEN
GOES TO OPEC.
YOU MEAN WE CAN'T RUN THIS
COUNTRY ON SKITTLES AND GUMMY
BEAR AND UNICORN HAIR?
WE ACTUALLY NEED OIL OUT THERE?
THE WHOLE THING IS A JOKE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FEEL THE
BRUNT OF THESE POLICIES AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BLAME THE
DEMOCRATS BECAUSE, YES, THEY ARE
IN CONTROL, THEY'LL PAY THE
PRICE THIS NOVEMBER.
>>, YOU KNOW, BEN, I WAS
THINKING ABOUT THEIR
DECISIONMAKING WHEN THEY REALLY
PUSH BIDEN TO THE FOREFRONT IN
THE NOMINATION PROCESS.
A LOT OF THE LEFT DIDN'T WANT
BIDEN, BUT HE WASN'T KIND OF --
HE WAS THE REASSURING CHOICE FOR
MIDDLE AMERICA.
BUT THEY NEEDED SOMEONE STRONG
SNRT WHO COULD KIND OF -- IN
THERE WHO COULD GIVE A STIFF-ARM
TO THE LEFT.
THEY MADE A BIG MISCALCULATION
WITH BIDEN.
HUGE MISCALCULATION IN THE END.
>> IT WAS A HUGE MISCALCULATION.
YOU AND I WERE THERE, LAURA, IN
SOUTH CAROLINA WHERE WE SAW
BIDEN KIND OF CEMENT THIS.
CLEARLY BACKED BY BARACK OBAMA.
I HAVE TO DISAGREE SLIGHTLY WITH
YOUR DEFINITION OF THE SUCCESS
OF THE LINCOLN PROJECT.
I THINK THEY WERE VERY
SUCCESSFUL AT COVERING UP THE
ATTEMPTS BY ONE OF THEIR
COFOUNDERS TO SOLICIT YOUNGER
MEN, AS WE'VE LEARNED OVER THE
YEARS.
>> RIGHT.
>> BUT I THINK WHEN IT CAME TO
THE SITUATION THAT WE SAW WITH
BIDEN, HE WAS SOMEONE THAT THEY
THOUGHT WOULD BE ABLE TO BE THIS
KIND OF MODERATE, NORMALCY BASED
CANDIDATE.
BUT WHAT WE'VE SEEN WHEN IT
COMES TO HIS PRESIDENCY IS
ANYTHING BUT.
HE HAS CAST ASIDE ANY OF THE
KIND OF NORM THAT IS WE TALKED
ABOUT, ACCEPTED OVER THE YEARS
ABOUT THE PRESIDENCY.
HE'S MADE OUR RELATIONSHIPS WITH
OUR ALLIES WORSE.
IN YOUR OPEN, HE HASLETT US IN
-- HE HAS LET US THROUGH HIS
FOREIGN POLICY DECISION, UP TO
THE BRINK OF POTENTIAL NUCLEAR
WARFARE WITH RUSSIA.
IT'S A COMPLETE DISASTER.
AND I THINK DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY,
WHEN YOU GIVE THEM A FEW BEARS
IN, THEY WILL ADMIT THIS TRUTH
ABOUT HIS PRESIDENCY.
BUT IT'S A HORRIBLE SITUATION
FOR THE COUNTRY.
IT'S THE WORSE KIND OF TIME FOR
A BIDEN PRESIDENCY.
AND HE'S REALLY LED US TO, I
THINK, ONE OF THE WORST
SCENARIOS THAT WE ARE FACING AS
A COUNTRY AT HOME AND ABROAD.
IT'S TERRIBLE IN LATELY OF
DIFFERENT WAYS.
>> NUCLEAR WAR, A POSSIBILITY,
BUT COVID APPARENTLY WAS A MUCH
WORSE POSSIBILITY FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAD VERY LITTLE RISK FOR SER